right so uh
I mean there's a crazy amount of new
technology happening here and it's all
evolving simultaneously so
um
we need to iron out like the
unknown unknowns so to speak
hello Internet I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it's November 29th
2022 we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube And blazetv subscribe if you
haven't especially at rumble.com Reuben
report you never know when YouTube is
just gonna pull the plug and we are
going to be talking about free speech
and big Tech and culture wars and race
and sexism and all sorts of stuff today
so it could happen at any given moment
uh actually what we're going to be
focusing on today is uh this absolute
Fiasco involving Kanye West Donald Trump
Milo yiannopoulos Nick Fuentes and now
Tim Poole you may not know some of those
names and if you don't know some of
those names you're probably lucky
because that means you're a little bit
out of the loop of like the hardcore
internet insanity but there's a lot of
weird things happening there's some
weird Juju some weird energy in the
world right now I want to address a
bunch of it head on and it sort of
culminated last night in Kanye showing
up on Tim Poole's podcast and you guys
know Tim Poole of Tim cast I was on his
show a couple weeks ago when we were
visiting DC Tim's a good dude Tim runs
an extremely extremely popular show
especially with young men online and he
was a I would say a former Lefty sort of
like me when I first met Tim about got
to be about seven years ago now he was
like dead ass broke basically living out
of his car had one little camera in a
dream and he's built like a really
interesting media Empire anyway Kanye
was on a show last night and walked out
so we're going to kind of Link
the craziness around Kanye and this race
stuff
to the big Tech stuff and the Twitter
stuff and a whole bunch more China
fouchy watch what we do on the program
today you know we like to tie all these
things together and I think we've tied
it real tight today uh so yes that is
what we're going to do today uh real
quick before we get to it let me talk to
you guys about kamikoto knives you know
it's time to up your kitchen knife game
with kamikoto knives using traditional
techniques kamikoto crafts beautiful
knives using steel Source from Japan
each blade is made with techniques that
have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife Smiths they come in
a beautiful heavy duty Ash wood box and
every blade is individually inspected
and comes with a lifetime guarantee
because of their single bevel Edge
kamikoto knives can achieve a wickedly
sharp edge the kind you just can't get
with other knives these are cut through
your rib eye like butter sharp kamikoto
knives are used by several chefs working
at Michelin star restaurants around the
world they make amazing gifts that come
in beautiful boxes you can maintain each
knife's edge with one of kamikoto's
sharpening wet stones and like I said
they're so confident in their product
that each knife comes with a lifetime
guarantee if you go ahead and buy now
kamikodo's offering an extra 50 bucks
off site wide on top of their Black
Friday sale go to Connie koto.com Reuben
and use offer code Reuben for an extra
50 off that's
k-a-m-i-k-o-t-o.com slash
reubencomicoto.com
Reuben okay so let's get into a little
bit I'm gonna get you caught up with a
bit of the insanity around Kanye West
now I'm I'm not a big rap guy I'm not a
huge fan of Kanye you guys know me I
like Frank Sinatra I like Frankie Valli
I like my chill channel it's not really
my thing but I have no doubt that he is
a very talented fella and he's made a
couple bucks in the biz the young people
like him okay so and I did see him once
I think I told the story once on the
show did I ever tell the story I saw
Kanye once when I lived in LA I was
going to Equinox the gym this little
sidebar but just come with me on this
one it's good uh and uh you know before
I have coffee during the day I cannot
function in the morning if I don't have
coffee I'm just not right and for some
reason
I was walking into the gym with David
we're walking in I hadn't had coffee and
I had headphones in it you know when you
have headphones in you talk real loud
you don't even realize it sometimes and
we're walking towards the stairs and
there I see Kanye and there were a lot
of like athletes and musicians and I
used to see Kevin Hart there and a whole
bunch of other people and because I'm
not really that's not my scene like you
see people I would see basketball
players they didn't wasn't sure if it
was a rapper whatever it might be I
there's Kanye I hadn't had coffee yet I
wasn't really thinking straight and I
loudly turned to David and I'm like hey
isn't that that guy what's his name and
Kanye looked at me he heard me and you
know when he can give you that scowl he
gave me the scowl so Kanye was not happy
with me anyway uh I uh a little sidebar
Kanye is having some weird issue with
the Jews he's not happy with the Jews
and and you guys know my feelings on
collectivism you cannot blame an entire
group of people for the way that some
people act everyone is responsible for
how they themselves act you watching
this right now whether you're white or
black or Jewish or Asian or whatever are
not representative of a larger Community
than what your actions are if you are a
white person and you do something bad we
shouldn't blame all white people if
you're a black person and you do
something bad we shouldn't blame all
black people but he's sort of caught up
in this in this
mess it's a real mess so anyway Kanye
then went a few days ago to Mar-A-Lago
to meet with Donald Trump but we'll get
to more on that in a second but
apparently it was set up a few weeks ago
before Kanye's crazy tweet remember his
crazy tweet about how he was going to go
Defcon 3 on the Jews which then got him
suspended on Twitter uh he went he had
dinner with Trump at Mar-A-Lago but he
brought Milo yiannopoulos and Nick
Fuentes now I don't even want to focus
on these guys really because they're
just sort of internet trolls they are
what they are I I will have a little bit
of a Maya culpa here just to start the
show you know I did several shows with
Milo over the years very very early on
and I did public events with Milo
um I maybe should have seen what he was
going to ultimately turn into and and be
a sort of racist Troll And whatever it
is so if I had anything to do with any
of his rise I actually fold me a culpa I
screwed the poochie on that one I don't
regret doing the interviews but maybe I
should have seen it a little more
succinctly this Fuentes guys just he's
just like a he's an actual self-avowed
white supremacist I mean he's a racist
and a white supremacist anyway they all
go to Mar-A-Lago together Trump's people
did not vet properly they had dinner
with him then Trump puts out a bunch of
statements we'll get to more on that in
just a second anyway uh Kanye Nick
Fuentes and Milo yiannopoulos went on
Tim Poole's show last night they start
ranting and raving about the Jews and
Tim did Tim did a fine job and Kanye
couldn't take it I I think I think
they've been extremely unfair to you who
was they though we can't tell you they
is cameras I'm not using the I don't use
the word as the way I guess you guys use
I'm talking to them though isn't it I
mean because no because when you think
about it consider it in 2018 what do you
mean it's not what do I mean like uh uh
okay so how about
are you leaving
are you afraid of the press
he's on
I'll say it right now
um
you got I I you guys want to bring that
stuff up
next question
you think yay is going to come in here
that was Tim's sidekick right there Luke
uh who chimed in at the end like have
the discussion I want to give real
credit to Tim Poole right now who again
I sort of came up with him he's a friend
and and I think he did a fine job there
he was willing to have the conversation
right we can all say all right you're a
racist you're an anti-semite you're a
big at blah blah blah Tim was willing to
sit down with these guys knowing that it
could very easily take him out too
um but he wanted to have that
conversation
um it's something that I've tried to do
for a long freaking time and then it
comes with a certain cost because if
people see you sitting with someone and
someone turns out to be a bad dude years
later they'll try to take you out but
Tim was really willing to do it he
wanted to have that conversation how can
we talk about specific ways that perhaps
you Kanye have been wrong without
lumping that into a whole group of
people a whole group of people who
history has not been that kind to by the
way
um and we see record levels of hate
crimes against Jews and and all of that
stuff so credit where credit is due and
what's interesting is that when you
challenge someone Tim barely challenged
Kanye barely he said that's not the
language that I want to use while
talking about this and then Kanye just
got up and left Kanye got up and left
and then and then Fuentes and Milo left
as well
um and this is why sunlight is the best
disinfectant if you have good ideas your
ideas will stand up to scrutiny if you
have truth on your side you can explain
truth honestly and clearly and cogently
and if your ideas are bad and they're
based in bigotry and they're based in
collectivism and you're not sure why you
believe what you believe but but you
damn well believe it then you're gonna
fold pretty quickly I mean Tim barely
pushed and Kanye absolutely uh folded it
continued a little bit after that after
they left the studio uh Tim's co-host
Luke runkowski uh he shared what Kanye
said to him as they were jumping in the
car as they were leaving the studio
outside they're in the car and I'm like
I'm like let's let's let the best idea
win you don't anything let's have this
conversation and essentially he said you
know
you don't believe in my truths
like this is my truth you guys are
denying it and I don't
you don't believe in my truth let's just
assume that that is a fairly accurate
assessment of what Kanye said to him you
know there is no your truth I mean
that's a it's funny Kanye who's now
thought of people think of him as like
this darling of the right now but the
idea of your truth is a very leftist
idea it's a very woke idea there is no
such thing as your truth just because
you believe something does not mean it
is true you can believe believe all
sorts of untrue things there is the
truth but there is not your truth but
you can then see the reason I'm playing
that for you is you can then see why
would Kanye get up Kanye believes
because he believes something he has
come to some conclusion that by him
saying it that that mean it that means
that it is true and that's not how it
works so Kanye is is off I would say in
a very dangerous place and everything
that Kanye is doing
is leftist it is based on all of the bad
ideas grouping people based off of race
and religion and or sexuality these are
the bad ideas a little context for why
they were there Tim was trying to and I
spoke for a few minutes with him on the
phone this morning Tim was trying to
just find out how this whole dinner
happened because it's like how did Trump
not realize that a white supremacist at
least one white supremacist and then a
kind of maybe half-white supremacist and
then Kanye with all the countries how
did this happen here's just quick video
of them at the Miami Airport on their
way to visit Trump which was being
shared online before they even got to
Mar-A-Lago so it's like did someone in
Trump's orbit think of maybe saying hey
uh we think that this white supremacist
guy this self-avowed white supremacist
I'm not just saying he's a white
supremacist he's a white supremacist by
his own words did someone think of Santa
Don hey maybe you don't want to have
dinner with this guy here's this quick
video of them at the airport
so that's on the way to Mar-A-Lago now
again Trump I don't want to get too lost
in the nitty-gritty of this but it is
important because Donald Trump wants to
be president again and you have to and I
voted for Trump I like Trump I hope to
interview him again I like and consider
his friends kids uh his kids friends
um
you know it's like
you gotta have people around you that
are going to vet this stuff properly so
let's get a little more context in into
actually what happened how the dinner
happened uh this is from the daily wire
former president Donald Trump reportedly
met with white supremacists and
Holocaust denier Nick Fuentes this week
at Mar-A-Lago the news comes after video
emerged early in the week showing
Fuentes with rapper Kanye West whose
recent anti-semitic tirades have been
upended have upended many of his
business Pursuits in an airport in Miami
West posted a video to his Twitter
account Thursday night titled Mar-A-Lago
debrief in which he says that Trump was
really impressed with Nick Fuentes
adding that Fuentes is a loyalist to
Trump other reports said that Trump was
dazzled by Fuentes according to people
who were present after news of the
meeting went viral Trump responded by
claiming that he knew nothing about
Fuentes when they met Kanye West very
much wanted to visit Mar-A-Lago Trump
said in the statement our dinner meeting
was intended to be Kanye and me only but
he arrived with a guest whom I've never
met and knew nothing about Trump also
posted to social to the social media
platform truth social explaining the
meeting with Fuentes this past week
Kanye West called me to have dinner at
Mar-A-Lago Trump wrote shortly
thereafter he unexpectedly showed up
with three of his friends whom I knew
nothing about we had dinner on Tuesday
evening with many members present on the
back patio the dinner was quick and
uneventful then they left for the
airport so I just want to address the
Trump part of this for just a second
again as someone that voted for Trump as
someone that might vote for Trump the
next time around Let's Pretend he had no
idea who I believe that it's very
possible he didn't know who Nick foyt
base was it seems less likely to me that
he didn't know who Milo was because he
was so integral in the culture War
during the the 2016 election but you
have to have people around you that vet
these things and if you think Kanye is
your friend then you're mistaken because
why would Kanye bring a white
supremacist to dinner with you knowing
that it would cause you this sort of
pain so in many ways this sort of feels
like Kanye set up Trump right but Kanye
wants to run for president that's what
he keeps saying right yay 24 so it's
like Kanye is kind of trying to take out
Trump but Trump there is blame on Trump
here either that he didn't either that
he knew who they were and he sat down
okay or he didn't and if he didn't that
he he has to fire some people at
Mar-A-Lago you have to fire your Chief
of Staff or someone around you that is
supposed to vet these people it's just
as simple as that so I want to just get
into a little more of the nitty-gritty
around all of this because there's a lot
of interesting stuff here so here's what
I posted on Twitter about this thing uh
about the clip that I just showed you
guys I haven't seen this all but good
for uh Tim pool for trying Fuentes is a
racist little troll rat uh you can fact
check me on that and Kanye's just lost
and drunk on Fame Trump really screwed
the pooch on this one and then I got a
lot of trump people very angry I
continued I've only seen another two
minutes of the whole thing as I've been
out to dinner but my guess is that Tim
pool did an admirable job in a shitstorm
and the others were likely exposed for
what they are plus it's good on the
internet to comment on things before
seeing them right and then I qualified
it with this and I like Trump I voted
for him and I've interviewed him I like
his kids but he's not perfect and I'm
not in a cult with an Untouchable leader
he has people who vet who he sits down
with for dinner and if he doesn't or
they screwed up that's not him or
Fuentes slash Kanye played him so that's
sort of I know this feels like a little
bit of Insider Twitter nitty-gritty and
who sat down with who like none of that
feels that important but it kind of all
does because it's it's all of the
machinations of what's leading up to 24
all of the censorship online how are
people on the right you know one of the
things we criticized the left all day
for right I do this almost every day on
the show I criticize the left because
they don't know how to put some
boundaries around their excesses right
so when when the racists of the left the
neo-racists and the real wokesters and
the gender crazy people and all those
things when they when they run Rampage
the good liberals never stand up to them
they they always fold in their face well
there's a challenge on the right right
now like what does the right wannabe
what does a broad conservative let's say
Coalition want to look like does it want
genuine racists to be part of it
um or does it want to be a little more
mature does it want to have some
leadership that knows how to stand up to
people and knows how to Enlighten people
on what actual individual rights and
American values are anyway Kanye
continued going after Ben Shapiro and
Ben Shapiro I don't know if you know
this he's Jewish it is true Kanye found
uh well apparently this tweet has since
been deleted by Kanye but Kanye wrote
Shapiro starvingly accepts a hundred
thousand from one of my opponents then
tries to trash me what he's referring to
there what you're seeing there is that
apparently Iran DeSantis Super PAC not
Iran DeSantis pack but around DeSantis
Super PAC which they're not associated
with the campaigns they apparently put a
whole bunch of money into advertising on
The Daily wire so when Kanye says from
one of my opponents he's calling Ron
DeSantis
one of his opponents because Kanye wants
to run for president which might be why
as I just said he wants to take out
Donald Trump uh Ben Shapiro saw that
tweet and said sadly you've trashed
yourself you didn't need my help it
wasn't me it wasn't the Jews it was just
you and that really is right I don't
blame anyone else for Kanye's Behavior
other than Kanye I don't blame anyone
else other than Milo or the swinte's guy
or whatever and by the way These Guys
these are people who have said
horrifically awful things about me I am
not demanding that they be taken to the
gulag or anything else but they should
be ignored and mocked and I don't know
not part of
decent Society like and that's not
that's not oh we have to have these
guard rails on society and really watch
what people say uh no if you're like
genuinely racist and you really want
different laws for different people uh
you can't you can't play with the adults
that's how it is they shouldn't be
censored they should just be ignored but
let's continue with how this is all
going because you can connect sort of
the craziness of this to the political
world in that Trump took a hit here and
what have I been saying for a while what
does the media want more than anything
else the media wants a freaking blowout
between Ron DeSantis and Donald Trump
and not only do they want that blowout I
my argument is and I think it's even
strengthened by the last let's say a
week or so is that they fear DeSantis
more than Trump because Trump comes with
all the baggage he comes with the
election denying stuff he comes with the
over-the-top stuff uh where DeSantis
doesn't have the baggage and has been
very functional so he is more of an
actual threat so Jonathan and cheat and
he is from is it from New you I always
said is it New York Magazine or New
Yorker can we just confirm that it's
from New York Magazine or New Yorker
we'll get it to you in just a second uh
he tweeted this out and I thought it was
just a perfect example of how you can
see the games of the media in real time
can we throw that tweet up there he
wrote Trump brought Nazis into the
periphery of the GOP Coalition and
DeSantis is saying is signaling he won't
change that so do you see what happened
here Trump has dinner
with the self-avowed white supremacist
and Kanye saying all his crazy stuff and
who does Jonathan chap try to make this
about Ron DeSantis and this is what the
media is going to do no matter what
Jonathan Chase from New York Magazine I
always confuse New York Magazine in New
Yorker I'm sure both of them are not
doing particularly well uh I retweeted
his little commentary there and I said
Trump's Fiasco dinner with the grifters
is really about check script DeSantis I
mean it's just silliness you guys get it
they're going to keep doing it but it's
I think it's important that we show you
those those little blips in it because
it is going to be the game whether Trump
runs the gamut and gets all the way to
24 or whether he drops out early or
whether DeSantis gets in or doesn't get
in or whatever it might be that is the
move that they are going to do and what
they're also going to do is consistently
go after Elon Musk Elon Musk who is
obviously the tech billionaire in a
Modern Renaissance guy who by his own
admission was is a lefty his entire life
never voted for a republican until about
six months ago when he voted for Myra
Flores the congresswoman in the Border
Town in Texas now that he's moved to
Texas because he escaped and got uh got
Tesla out of California the media is
going after him and why are they going
after him because all he's doing is
saying hey I'm just trying to make sure
we can respect Free Speech a little bit
more on Twitter what a freaking headache
he chose to get involved in he could
have gotten his family on a rocket and
gone to Mars instead he's fighting for
our mortal lives here on planet Earth
but they're very upset with him because
somehow to the left and to the machine
as it operates Free Speech me is somehow
a a connection to the alt-right and mean
people on the right I think free speech
is just about the marketplace of ideas
and good ideas will win out over time
but I'm old school Elon tweeted this
because he's not happy with what's going
on here because he's getting hit hard
and it's and it's hitting Twitter's
bottom line Apple has mostly stopped
advertising on Twitter do they hate free
speech in America
what's going on here Tim Cook Tim Cook
of course is the CEO of Apple and then
Jonathan Chait same guy who I just
referenced a moment ago for going after
DeSantis in something that had nothing
to do with DeSantis he wrote try posting
more conspiracy theories and white
supremacist memes that ought to bring
them back okay so first off Elon Musk
has not posted any white supremacist
memes this is complete nonsense and the
idea that somehow Twitter can't be a
place where people share conspiracy
theories well I don't know Donald Trump
very fine people on both sides Brett
Kavanaugh as a serial rapist you know
all this stuff right we could we could
literally just go through these all day
the Jesse Smollett Oaks all of these
things the covid shots work masks work
lockdowns work this has all been pushed
by the power structure they were pushing
lies and conspiracy theories now there's
a little bit of pushback and giant
corporations are pulling ads out of
Twitter because of that even though
Twitter's usage is now at an all-time
high Ai and apple is considering at
least some people are reporting apple is
considering booting Twitter off the app
store which is crazy oh it's absolutely
crazy so it's not just that Elon bought
Twitter and is expanding Free Speech
it's that he's exposing the left and I
don't want to just say the left here
it's he's exposing the power structure
the cultural norms of corporate press
and and all of the the journalistic
outlets he's he's exposing them for what
they are they are tyrants they are the
machine and they're losing a bit of
control so now here's an Incredible
video so this is a video at the white
house yesterday and there's a Reuters
journalist the woman that you're about
to see asking the question her name is
Andrea shawal she is part of the world
economic Forum well done snoops on the
internet uh it turns out she's a world
economic Forum affiliate so she works
for Reuters listen to the question the
leading question that she asks Karin
John Pierre about Elon Musk and Twitter
and listen to Korea I mean Korean jump
here do I have to tell you what I think
you know what I think about her but
listen to her nonsense look at her body
language the eyes the whole thing just
it's all it's gross prepare yourself for
Pure grossness enjoy it's a critical
moment really in terms of
um ensuring that Twitter does not become
a vector for misinformation I mean are
you concerned about the you know Elon
Musk says there's more and more
subscribers coming online are you
concerned about that and what tools do
you have who is it at the White House
that is really keeping track of this so
look this is something that we're
certainly uh keeping an eye on and uh
look um we you know we have always been
very clear
um and that when it comes to social
media platforms it is their
responsibility to make sure that when it
comes to misinformation when we when it
comes to the hate that we're seeing uh
that they they take action that they
continue uh to take action again we're
all keeping a close eye on this we're
all uh monitoring uh what's what's
currently occurring and uh we see you
know we see it with our own eyes of what
you all are reporting and just for for
ourselves what's happening on Twitter uh
but again social media companies have a
responsibility to prevent their
platforms uh from being used by any user
uh to incite violence especially
violence uh directed at individual
communities as we have been seeing and
the president has been very clear on
calling that out he'll continue to do
that and we're going to continue to
monitor the situation go ahead Mamma Mia
all right there's so much there so just
to be clear again the woman who asked
the question the journalist who asked
the question is in cahoots with the
world economic Forum what kind of
question is it when a journalist is
asking the White House Press Secretary
she's in essence saying hey can you guys
censor more can you figure out a way so
that people can't share what they think
and then cringe up here's a uh answer
and you know her body language and the
looking down the entire time it's just
such full of nonsense
um she first she says that it is not
that it is their responsibility that
it's big Tech's responsibility social
media platforms responsibility to watch
out for misinformation no it's not where
does it say that these are companies
that can do whatever they want we have
the Bill of Rights and the Constitution
that protect our rights right but it is
not their responsibility to do that you
might like them to do that and by the
way let's not forget the Jen saki uh she
told us that the White House Flags post
for Facebook's so they are using big
Tech to encroach on your free speech and
I suspect that they know that Elon knows
it right because Elon right now has all
the records of what's gone on at Twitter
over the last couple years and do you
think as he's flipping through the
records he's going boy this is odd we
got an email from someone and I'm just
giving an example here uh this is very
bizarre we got a email from somebody in
the administration uh who or from
intelligence Services who wanted us to
uh get rid of Donald Trump uh boy we
have something here from somebody in the
intelligence Services FBI CIA who wanted
us to hide the hunter buying laptop like
the whole Jig Is up I think Elon has the
keys to expose all of the craziness and
he's implying by the way that he's going
to do it uh so she says it's their
responsibility and that they should take
action well if you're forcing them to
take action then that isn't a direct
violation of the First Amendment right
it's not the government coming but if
the government forces a company to clamp
down on your free speech again what they
call this disinformation or
misinformation even though they're the
Premier agents of the stuff this is a
problem uh and and of course the flag
post point that I made before uh anyway
I actually uh tweeted about this very
thing so I tweeted the video out there I
said absolutely insane watching the
machine go after Elon Musk for defending
Free Speech this whole exchange is
Kabuki theater from the ridiculous
leading question by the quote journalist
to kgp kjp's obvious pre-planned
response and Elon Musk uh oh well here I
I had a little bit of a threat on it I
said also can anyone point to how hate
has been increased since Elon Musk took
over I get tons of wacko mostly
Anonymous loser trolls in my mentions I
ignore blocker mute people are mean
online that doesn't give the government
a right to trample on the First
Amendment and Elon Musk actually
responded to me and he said why are so
many in the media against Free Speech
this is messed up I want to address the
hate thing for just a second
um you know yesterday when I tweeted
this thing out and I was my mildly
critical of trump right it was mild
criticism like like he has to have
better people around him or vet people
of war with while also qualifying it by
saying I voted for the guy I like the
guy I like his kids all of that stuff
um I got a gajillion people like the
troll type people calling me horrible
things and I block them or mute them or
whatever did I complain at dinner about
it last night guys and took the team out
for dinner it was Phoenix's birthday no
we had our Margaritas we enjoyed our
Hawaiian steak at Hillstone and uh we
did not complain about that people said
mean things to me I don't know that
there's any indication that there is
more hate right now and if you are
getting a lot of hate online you're not
going to believe this you know what you
can do with this thing you can throw it
out the window
bananas bananas bananas uh but this is
what's happening and you can feel what
the next move is the next move is to
somehow go after Elon Musk right we've
shown you uh all sorts of uh videos of
Representatives Ed Markey Senator Ed
Markey who said that if Elon doesn't
control the speech on Twitter a little
bit more that the government might look
into his companies I mean this is
fascism they're everything that they
purport us to be uh here is former U.S
representative from Maryland Donna
Edwards uh basically blaming Twitter and
Tucker Carlson for violence you you can
see the linkage between the violent
rhetoric and these crimes attacking this
marginalized community and I think it
puts all of us at risk and I have to say
I have real questions about these
platforms like Twitter that continue to
amplify and allow this kind of hateful
language that then plays in to violence
happening I think you know I mean it has
to it has to stop and and these
platforms have to bear some
responsibility for their role in
contributing to it and I don't even have
much to say about a Tucker Carlson or
anybody else who lifts up violence and
glorifies violence against the community
and then says hands off when it comes to
violence it actually does happen in that
I should have warned people that it was
an MSNBC clip the televised mental
institution does that woman not realize
does she not have a mirror and realize
that if she believes that Tucker Carlson
is saying mean things about people and
that's instigating violence that when
she then says mean things about Tucker
Carlson that she's instigating violence
on him now putting that aside for a
second because I get it these people
don't get irony or reality
um Tucker Carlson is not for violence I
have never heard him call for violence
people do say mean things online and
it's very bizarre because for these last
couple years where many people in
mainstream media have called all half
the country white supremacists and Nazis
that seems pretty mean if you got called
to Nazi would you say I don't like that
very much yeah people don't like being
called the Nazi I guess if you're not
and I guess if you're a Nazi you go well
I am a Nazi but generally speaking when
people are called Nazis they're not
Nazis okay so if you guys have been
doing that have you been promoting
violence against half the country who
are actually not Nazis
lordy lordy Elon tweeted this out which
pissed off CNN so this is a fake
headline obviously uh CNN Elon Musk
could threaten free speech on Twitter by
literally allowing people to speak
freely I think the CNN Communications
Department actually tweeted out that
that was fake that's how stupid this
whole thing is but that's all he's doing
he is not try he is trying to make it so
that the the scale is even as opposed to
we are going to inflate everything by
the left and we are going to deflate
everything by the right he's trying to
just say hey it's even and that's what
freaks these people out because if they
didn't have a monopoly on information
then I actually think the country would
look very different I think people would
vote very differently I think our
culture would feel very differently and
they're losing power which is why there
are no doubt
think about it there are no doubt
meetings right now happening at Apple
where they're they're now debating
whether Twitter can be on the App Store
there are no doubt meetings at the white
house right now figuring out how they
can put pressure on Elon Musk you know
maybe we should look into his finances
related to Tesla or SpaceX because if we
put enough pressure on maybe he'll ease
up and do what we want to do this is
dangerous stuff this is dangerous Banana
Republic type stuff but it is happening
here they're not going after him just
because he's for free speech they're
going after him because he's exposing
the machine we've got examples of it
look what he found this is from Elon
Musk look what he found in the Twitter
headquarters closet I assume they have a
few closets here's what he found in one
closet here we are uh at the March
things and there's an entire
entire closet full of secret closet of
hashtag woke the t-shirts stay woke
people you gotta stay woke do you think
that that's indicative of what the
culture around there was like that it
was mostly woke leftists running the
company and perhaps they were putting
their foot on the scale right perhaps
they were limiting the reach of
dangerous people like me and inflating
the reach of good worksters like AOC you
think you think maybe yeah uh well you
know what's also happening along with
all of this uh other corporations it's
not just big Tech other big companies
are being exposed for what they are uh
in essence woke nut jobs uh you may have
heard about this story this story about
Balenciaga the fashion brand Balenciaga
we've got some info here from the daily
wire parents erupted in Outrage over
fashion brand Balenciaga using young
children to advertise what one critic
dubbed bondage teddy bear purses the
high-end brand is known for its
outrageous fashion and is often worn by
celebrities like Kim Kardashian model
Bella Hadid and actress Nicole Kidman
the daily wire was able to confirm the
following photos where on valenciaga's
website as of Monday morning here's a
couple of the images I mean is this
stuff really for kids what are we doing
with these teddy bears bondage teddy
bears with kids and it's like what is
all of this stuff but wokeness has
infected everything and people think
anything is okay right it's just so
bizarre we have to put up a warning we
got the warning going you're about to
see the harpies on The View
they talked about Balenciaga and sort of
maybe made a little sense related to it
kind of maybe sort of I'll let you
decide what's going on I found this ad
campaign particularly just tasteful in
this moment so there's this there's
growing anti-lgbtq sentiment right now
and it how it's Being Framed is as
portraying you know trans people as
groomers this is a term you'll hear on
the far right they're groomers this is
where you get the anti-drag queen stuff
that we're seeing so Balenciaga played
right into their hands by having kids in
a sexualized manner carrying something
that represents you know sex acts I
think it was a really bad misstep at a
moment where it's just kind of a
dangerous time to even give Credence to
those kind of insane takes yeah I mean
we can't even show the picture because
it's so distasteful but what's also very
distasteful is like Balenciaga lately I
mean their stuff is just ugly I mean the
bag that the little girl is holding is
ugly do you remember when Kim K was
dressed in Balenciaga for the game
look at that it looked like a bat or
something I mean I think I gave them a
little too much credit that they made
some sense look they make some sense in
that okay the pictures were gross but
their analysis of what's going on here
really makes no sense first off uh
Allison Farah she's the fake
conservative that was talking at first
so she's the one that's allowed to be a
little bit on the right but she always
have to like go after Republicans on the
show it's just such an absolute farce
um she says she talks about the growing
anti-lgbtq sentiment you guys know my
feelings about these these letter
alphabet nonsense
um these letters make no sense I have
nothing more in common with a trans
person than a straight person does
they've just combined all of these
things to take the individual out of all
of these things there is not growing
anti-lgbtq violence there really isn't
what people are concerned about is
pushing the gender stuff on children and
so she's claiming oh they call them all
groomers no one's calling all gay people
or even all trans people groomers
they're calling the people who want to
endlessly talk to Children about sex and
gender identity groomers I don't know
what other word it would be if you were
is a third grade teacher and you were
supposed to be teaching the Kid 2 plus 2
equals four and instead after school you
meet with the little boy and you call
him by a girl's name and then you hide
that information from the parents for
months and months and people at the
school call him the girl's name but you
don't want the parents to know I don't
know what else to call you besides
groover I probably could find some other
words but we will get demonetized so no
one is saying that that's what all gay
people want it's it's a damn shame
what's going on here because for all for
the obvious equality that gay people
have it is now the radical woke leftists
that are that are instigating some hate
around them because of this very
nonsense uh but there's this weird thing
with excessive tolerance now Jordan
Peterson often talks about this
tolerance cannot be your highest most
important goal in the hierarchy of life
because you will be tolerant of
everything this is
sadly what has happened to the modern
Democrat Party and liberals as uh as a
sort of blanket statement so Balenciaga
okay they have kids in bondage it's very
weird but this is happening throughout
the corporate world there's other
bizarre things going on uh the daily
wires Luke rosiak was on Tucker Carlson
last night and they've got something
weird going down uh with JetBlue I it's
not related to sex which is nice but
check it out so the majority of people
dying right now of covet have been
vaccinated against covet obviously
didn't work the majority so with that in
mind it's a little weird to learn that
the airline jet blue is still refusing
to hire people who haven't taken the
covet vaccine even though they're the
minority people who are dying of covet
they say it's part of their commitment
to safety but as it turns out that
commitment to safety does have limits so
JetBlue is hired a violent felon called
John Perry's as a pilot
this man spent nine years in prison for
breaking into the home of a judge he's
on probation until 2044.
yeah John Perry has committed a heinous
crime he broke into the home of a judge
and brutally assaulted the judge's
daughter in the shower with a metal
baton she fled the home bloodied and
naked when he was arrested he was found
wearing a bulletproof vest and in his
car he had knives handcuffs parachute
cord and most disturbingly a shovel so
this is a bat now JetBlue forced all 25
000 of its employees to get vaccinated
last year whether they liked it or not
they won't hire you if you haven't had
the vax but they did hire John Perry's
do you see how whacked out everything is
this guy attacked a judge with a metal
baton and had a shovel a shovel people
you know what you do with the shovel you
dig a hole and then you might throw
somebody in that hole anyway he spent
nine years in jail I don't know more
about the story and maybe the guy has
been completely changed and found the
Lord and all the stuff but he's now a
pilot for JetBlue I like JetBlue I like
those mid seats Daphne we may have to I
have to get on another airline now
because of this I can't have this guy
flying me after all this with the shovel
um but this guy is hired and 25 000
people that work for JetBlue have to be
vaccinated and they will not hire people
if they are not vac so I'm just trying
to show you the asymmetry of craziness
here you could have a perfectly good
pilot great track record never tried to
murder a judge doesn't have a shovel
we're not going to hire him because he's
on vacs we're going to hire this guy but
these sort of inconsistencies I think
people are seeing them everywhere Tucker
also did a segment talking about the NBA
and the NBA which you know really pushed
black lives matter on everybody pushed
masking push kneeling for the flag has
done every anti-American thing possible
LeBron James the biggest star in all of
basketball he is a he's a slave in
essence to China while he will
constantly rail against the country and
the political system that made him
probably worth he's got to be worth 200
million bucks at at least I would
imagine uh so Tucker actually went after
after the NBA for their stance or lack
thereof when it comes to China we hear a
word from the NBA commission that would
be Adam over now Adam Silver also spends
a lot of time yelping about what an
authoritarian country this is and
threatening the people who live here
with punishment
he has no problem threatening American
voters in North Carolina for example or
in Texas who wanted separate bathrooms
for little girls
what does he think of killing people for
wanting to leave their apartment
or throwing people on Moss into
concentration camps we decided to find
out so we emailed this office today to
get his view of Chinese concentration
camps what does Adam Silver think of
that one of our Premier moral voices we
didn't get a reply why is that maybe
because he has made Millions personally
in the NBA itself makes billions of
dollars in China
so the NBA has no word to say about
China throwing its population in the
concentration camps turning Shanghai
into a prison
okay so this is super interesting
because the NBA needs new markets right
any business needs new markets they've
sort of maxed out what they can do with
the United States a certain amount of
people love basketball certain amount of
people don't watch they know roughly how
many people are going to be watching all
the time they have to find new markets
to bring in new money I would say also
the NBA has lost a lot of fans someone
like me because it's become so
politicized but again they were the
pushers of BLM they had the black
hashtag black lives matter on the court
for an entire season right the whole
thing turned out to be the the greatest
grift of all time so they can constantly
have their players and the organization
itself railing against the United States
and what Tucker referenced there was in
North Carolina and Texas where they
wanted separate bathrooms they didn't
want say I I don't know does it sound so
crazy you wouldn't want to say a 23 year
old man in a dress going into the
woman's bathroom with little girls crazy
right because North Carolina and Texas
were going to pass laws around that they
decided not to hold the All-Star Game in
those cities so they're very very
principled the NBA but oddly quiet about
China now what could be going on in
China right now well we showed you a
couple of videos yesterday China has
their Communist party which wants
complete control of their citizens lives
uh they have a zero coveted policy
it is it is not this is a phrase but it
is not something that is real there is
no such thing as zero covet we will
never get covered down to zero we will
never get the flu down to zero or the
common cold or twisted ankles down to
zero so they have a zero covid policy
which really is just a policy to see how
they can break their people how they can
enslave their own citizens uh and there
is all sorts of awful stuff they are
literally locking hundreds of thousands
of people into their homes and apartment
buildings uh under the guise of the zero
covet policy here's a little video
foreign
these are massive skyscrapers that they
are locking people in people are dying
of starvation people are jumping out of
Windows I mean it's it's horrific and if
you don't think that's dystopian enough
here is a drone flying around a city in
China warning people to stay at home
foreign
[Applause]
that's right out of a Philip K dick
futuristic movie right the Drone the
robot flying around to make sure people
stay at home so they don't get sick from
other people as the government locks
them in their houses I mean it's
absolute dystopian insanity but now it's
connected to what's going on here in the
United States Anthony fauci who probably
should be in jail and I consider him an
evil mad scientist the highest paid
person on the government payroll by the
way although he is as he always says not
political and he also is the science the
guy's a lot
um he was on Jake Tapper show Jake
Tapper obviously a Democrat activist and
Demi and Jake to his credit every now
and again this is why people like Jake
because every now and again even though
he's 90 hacky he gets one right every
now and again so he actually asked fauci
about these Chinese lockdowns and really
listen to what fauci says here this is
this is really really interesting the
China's official news agency today
published an op-ed asserting that the
country's strict coveted measures are
signed scientific and effective are they
well when you want to shut down uh in
order to interrupt immediately a process
that's going on like the spread of
infection there should be a purpose to
it like you want to make sure you get
enough ventilators or enough PPE or you
want to get your population
vaccinated the comment that I made about
their severe
actions that they've taken is that you
have to have an end game what's the
purpose if the purpose is let's get all
the people vaccinated particularly the
elderly then okay for a temporary period
of time to do that but they have very
very strict type of a lockdown they're
locking people in their homes which is
really they can't even go out and from
what I hear shop or walk a dog or
something like that okay so what's
interesting first let's start with
Tapper first his question are they
effective meaning are the lockdowns
effective
it's a moot point whether they're
effective or not it's actually a moot
point they let's just pretend for a
second that lockdowns that these extreme
draconian
lockdowns Were Somehow effective in
limited Co in limiting covet that
doesn't mean that they would be right
and that's so when Tapper uses the word
effective even if they were effective it
does not mean you are not trampling on
people's rights that's in fact exactly
what you are doing uh and then when
fauci the interesting part on fauci is
when he talks about the end game well
okay if if the end game would be to just
get more elderly people uh vaccinated
then they'd be safe so it would be okay
but does he not have any basic
understanding I mean we played a video
of him saying virtually the same thing
yesterday there this has nothing to do
with covid it is a government seeing how
far it can push its own people much like
will be happening over the next few
years in blue cities and states who
voted in the exact same people who
locked him in last time so do you think
that the people who did who use those
levers of power and then all of the
citizens who said thank you sir may I
have another do you think that the
people who push that on them do you
think they might go why don't we do it
again
don't worry we're gonna eat our foie
gras on the boat while these morons are
staying at their house so what's
interesting about all of this also is
that China which is not known for
protests right they have the Tiananmen
Square protest 30 40 years ago but China
generally does not uh take too kindly to
mass protests well there are protests
bursting out all over the country now
you're not going to see any of these
really on mainstream media because
mainstream media doesn't want you the
people realizing that you have any power
that's just how it is uh here is
assistant Secretary of Defense John
Kirby uh saying basically that uh no
we're not going to stand with the
protesters and uh you know they can
basically go f themselves
I'm wondering what is the president's
reaction when he hears protesters in
China chant Freedom or Xi Jinping step
down the president's not going to speak
for protesters around the world they're
speaking for themselves
so there's no reaction these protesters
are speaking for themselves what we are
doing is making it clear that we support
the right of peaceful protests
what an absolute spineless
Howard what a disgusting group of people
that we have in the Oval Office right
now we really do these These are
anti-American anti-free anti-freedom
focused people
Howards these people we are watching
citizens be locked on in their own homes
on top of the the genocide of the eugers
right we know that this is all happening
but we want to make money off China so
we're not going to say anything so we'll
just let the protesters say they're
think sure the government's going to
crack down on them probably kill a whole
bunch of them a bunch of them will be
unpersoned and missing but we're not
going to really why the president you
know sure if they were protesting racism
of the United States we'd be all about
it but we ain't going to do that
Lord Lord help me uh anyway what do we
do about all this what do we do about
all this because it's kind of scary it's
kind of dystopian it feels like it's
kind of getting worse and uh and what do
you do what do you do in the midst of
all that so I would say to turn the the
tides the tone of our government and our
culture you want to turn this thing
whether it's Kanye Twitter Balenciaga
JetBlue the U.S position on China we
have to look back on historical
injustices we have to realize that there
are good ideas out there that's why
sunlight is the best disinfectant look
how quickly Kanye folded in in the face
of someone being like well you don't
want to say all of those people and then
the guy walked off that's a good win we
want to keep exposing the bad ideas of
collectivism collectivism of Marxism of
socialism of Communism and we want to
contrast it with Western values that you
have a little value and you have
autonomy over your life and all of those
things I found this video a couple days
ago that I wanted to figure out how we
could work it in the the show and I
thought this would be a beautiful way of
tying this all together this is Jordan
Peterson talking about historical
dangers of authoritarianism collectivism
socialism
Etc people are
unbelievably ignorant about history and
I mean I would include myself in that
you know I mean
I mean I I know what I know about
history say preceding the 20th century
is very sketchy it's embarrassingly
sketchy you know
um and what young people know about 20th
century history is non-existent
especially about the history of the
radical left when how would they know
communist and Marxist ideology is very
good at addling the at the weak minds of
idiot intellectuals there is a huge
section of the population who was
fomenting I suppose against the standard
what would you call it political
psychological and social order you see
in the western intellectuals tried to
make excuses for what had happened in
the Soviet Union by blaming it on
Stalin's
Cult of Personality perversion of the
original accurate Marxist Doctrine still
hear people today many people when
they're faced with the you know if
they're if they're if they're Marxist in
their orientation and they're faced with
the data pertaining to what happened in
the Soviet Union they'll say something
like well that wasn't real Marxism but
one of the things that you might answer
to that is well fine except that in
every bloody country in the world where
that Doctrine was implemented regardless
of the wide cultural differences between
the cultures say the Soviet Union China
Cambodia and so forth exactly the same
thing happened every time the Marxist
claims to sympathy with the working
class because you might say well they
actually have sympathy for the working
class are they really trying to put
their
um their their their their positions
forward their needs forward or do they
just hate the successful depending on
how that's divided up I thought well how
do you make a judgment like that and I
have this personal experience but then I
thought well that that's easy with
Marxism it's like you just look at all
the murders
and you then you know whether that was
a movement that was genuinely motivated
by empathy
all right guys so we know what we're
fighting and if you know what you're
standing for I think you'll fight it
effectively and there will be places say
here in the Free State of Florida that
will build the machinery and have the
right political leaders and the right
Spirit amongst the people to fight these
things and we have to figure out how to
export that blueprint as I've been
talking about and certain places we
won't be able to export it to because
they'll be so entrenched say like a
California and the bad ideas will always
keep coming but we will do our best to
look to history to know what could be in
front of us if we don't fight for
Freedom right and that's how we'll get
out of this whole thing
solid show today if I do say so myself a
couple comments from the locals
Community Margot says Dr falchenstein
should be on charges for mass murder I
mean he should be
embarrassed to be out like the guy
thinks he's a God if you criticize me
you're really criticizing science right
vile disgusting he lied we've shown you
the videos lying about masks lying about
his involvement in lockdowns and school
shutdowns and all of these things just
absolute embarrassment and they still
put him up there it's just incredible
Jeannie says I think you're wrong is
violent speech to these lefties right I
mean it really is as simple as that what
they really don't want is just people
saying um actually I think something
different uh no no uh no well actually
that isn't really right and I think
something a little bit different and I'd
like to explain it that is one so that's
what's happening as Elon is just saying
hey we're going to allow more voices to
be in the mix
suddenly boom
hates Beach yo EK says can't spare
anything for Epstein's Client List but
they'll investigate Twitter isn't that
something right it's like
Epstein died in jail it was odd that the
cameras didn't work I don't want to be a
crazy conspiracy theorists the security
guards weren't around the cameras didn't
work uh we never got the the list
Giselle whatever whatever her name is
Gisele Maxwell she got indicted we never
got the list on that one very very
bizarre I don't know how do you indict
somebody without knowing what they were
doing
guys if you haven't subscribed do so at
rumble.com reubenreport I have enjoyed
Today's Show I hope you have share it
with friends talk about these ideas
let's win why not have a great Tuesday
everybody we leave you with a cold close
of uh the elderly man pretending to be
president being banged up in one of the
debates way back when we should have
known he had nothing but alas here we
are see ya see people miss this
opportunity and lose because we are
nominating someone that doesn't isn't
trusted doesn't have authentic
connection
and so that's what's on the ballot and
issues do matter I I have a lot of
respect uh for for the vice president he
is swore me into my office as a hero
this week I hear him literally say
that I don't think we should legalize
marijuana I I I I thought you might have
been high when you said it and
let me tell you
because
marijuana in our country is already
legal for privileged people and it's won
the War on Drugs has been a war on black
and brown people
I uh you know I'm part of that that
Obama Coalition I come out of the black
community in terms of my support if you
notice I have more people supporting me
in the black community that have nouns
for me because they know me they know
who I am three former chairs of the
black caucus the only black
African-American woman that ever been
elected to the United States Senate a
whole range of people my point is true
I said but first things
come first